[Musik]
vor das paar Jahren habe ich mich als
mögliche
das ist total unkompliziert und euch
meinen Teil von der Welt bitte Datenbank
und da damit potenzielle Lebens
aber auch im Wissen dass Chance dass ich
jemals auch fragt wird für spannend auch
sehr gering ist und dann aber furchtbar
machen
[Musik]
und ja es ist mega überraschen sie aber
das hat mir auch irgendwie berührt und
auch Freude dass ich die Möglichkeit
bekommen
kann mich jetzt entschieden dass ich die
Spannweite
ungefährlich und ich finde halt der
Aufwand wo ich an oder das Opfer wo ich
muss bringe sind Verhältnis zu dem wo
die Spannung bei anderen Mütze mega mega
für mich
intensiver Prozessor ich bin schon
vorgewandt wurde ab körperlich wird das
nicht ganz einfach ich mache mich
erstmal auf den Weg und ich Spital in
Zürich
ich habe jetzt einen Termin vom Spital
in Zürich für den medizinische check
ich habe bis zu 3 Stunden gegangen auf
alles testet wird und befragt
wirklich Gesundheit machen
als erstes muss ich ein ausführlichen
Fragen zum Gesundheitszustand ausführen
schlagstreifen
Lungenembolie Bewusstlosigkeit nein nein
[Musik]
die ganze Zeit zurück von Diagnosen und
nachher es gibt entspannter und den
transportationen
eigentlich
gar nicht realisiert was überhaupt
passiert also ja und dann die Diagnose
DAX ist okay
und andere Leute die Jahre ja das ist
einfach
okay das klappt und es gibt aber
irgendwo auf der Welt wo mir hilft
gerade
[Applaus]
ja das ist meine erste Tagen
[Musik]
Termin im zuständigen Arzt dem
Herrschinger erklärt mir nochmal im
Detail über blutstandzahl spannend
sie werden das nicht machen dass sie
sich früher tätig meldet will bin
Patient für das behütete Chemotherapie
nicht mehr anders überlegen das
Konsequenzen
Berlin
[Musik]
und Frau spörle lernt man auch schon mal
Spritze mit der Wachstumsfaktoren hier
würde ich mir selber Spritze müsse damit
sich meine Blutstammzellen
ja es wird langsam konkreter
gesehen
einfach nur
beruhigend Erlaubnis entspannt
überraschen die Ergebnisse gut ich bin
gesund und als Spender geeignet
was aber wenn kein Spender gefunden wird
ich reise zum Roten Kreuz nach Bern von
da aus werden alle Transplantationen der
Schweiz koordiniert
Familienmitglied helfen wie oft Gott das
das funktioniert
und das ist jetzt 20 bis 30 prozentige
Maschine
180 Menschen das sehr viel aber wenn man
bedenkt dass
der Patientin und Spandau sehr genau
bessere Chemie Spender in der jm-spandus
in der Register hat
genau
Transplantation das ist schwierig sage
das ist wirklich sehr individuell also
ungefähr 70 Prozent von der Patienten wo
man transplantiert sind kalt oder
überleben die ersten zwei Jahren nach
Transplantationen
jede vierte Patient kein passende
spenden
in der Regel schlechter und man musste
noch Therapie alternative Chemotherapie
[Musik]
der erste Injektion wird ihn unterstützt
viel besonders die sind schon instruiert
wurde relativ entschieden
[Musik]
ab jetzt spritze ich zweimal am Tag
selbstständig mir selber spritzen
sollte
ich nicht spannend
genug
[Musik]
und so richtig Gliederschmerzen
aber wenn ich denke dass die spannend
nutzen kann sind sie vernachlässigbar in
deine vier Tage
wirkliche schwierig zu schaffen
entscheiden
es ist auch sehr morgen dass ich jetzt
die letzte zarte Spritze vor der Spanne
die drei Stunden ist spannend
und ich bin recht frohes die letzte Welt
die letzten zwei Tage
[Musik]
wunderschön wunderschön
vier bis sechs Stunden unter spannen
mit der Kamera und gleichzeitig super
und so funktioniert das ganze
restlichen Blut wird dann wieder zurück
gleitet
cool super
[Musik]
der Maschine mittlerweile
werden
er fahren
wird
[Musik]
sbüro
das volkszeit spannenderen du weißt
schon Auto hast
nein also
auf dem Beatles
gesehen
junge genau
irgendwie keine Ahnung
[Musik]
ja und irgendwie fanatisch mehr Licht
verbunden
mit meiner Blut Stammzellen fühlt sich
noch 288 Minuten also knapp fünf Stunden
[Musik]
spannende ist jetzt
und ich muss zuerstow während dem ganze
Prozess von der spritzen und einfach
entspannz
Bezug verlorene
[Musik]
und hat damit
also eins zwei Tage bleiben aber jetzt
fühle mich wieder mega gut eigentlich
wie vorher und jetzt noch
vom
Transplantationszentrum vom Empfang oder
Empfängerin auf Englisch also ganz kurz
und ich hoffe der Patienten der patience
family out like to thank you don't for
the generosity and breaches Gift passion
vielleicht bekomme auch nur Nachricht
vom Empfänger oder Empfängerin sauber es
gibt jedenfalls Möglichkeit
sogar schon registriert schreibst du
doch in die Kommentare und wenn sie die
Reportagen